hi everyone i'm joanna and i have my
good friend here with me wendy wendy is
a certified pilates and yoga instructor
i am really excited to go through this
stretch session with you today
hi everyone today we will take you
through a series of combination of yoga
for stretching and pilates core
strengthening it will be a perfect
balance of strength and flexibility we
think of it as
i am we will be doing it in time with
the music but i will be giving you
options so take the options that feels
good for you today
remember it should challenge you but you
shouldn't be struggling in it yep i know
i will be taking the options and if you
are watching me struggling don't worry
about it it's going to be fun
um but let's do this together okay let's
do this
[Music]
we're going to start with sun salutation
as your warm up so step up right at the
top of the mat take a deep breath in
with lift through the hands
exhale come on down like diving forward
hands to the floor hands to shins feel
the stretch on the back of your legs
touch down right foot takes a big step
back hips down chest up
downward dog push through the hands feet
hip distance
come forward into your plank
you can bring your knees down whenever
you need slowly lower elbows into the
ribs hips down shoulders back either
halfway or all the way upward dog
downward dog lift the hips push your
heels down bend your knees eyes up right
foot forward you can help your foot if
you don't make it
feet together come on in
take a deep breath in we reach to the
top stand tall
exhale open wide to the side hands
beside your body keep moving we breathe
as you lift
exhale just melt
hands to shins breathe in chest up
breathing out touch down left foot big
step back
feet hip distance think about pushing
your thighs back into your down dog
come forward for your plank abs switched
on you can drop to the knees if you need
elbows into the ribs hips down shoulders
back push to the hands and straighten
the arms
hips to the roof lift
heels down
bend the knees eyes up
left foot coming through
feet together
take a deep breath in imagine breathing
from the toes right up to the heads
exhale to open stand tall
keep moving inhale use your breath to
move you
exhale fold
how much can you let go
hands to shins breathing
exhale touch down right foot goes back
downward dog push to the hands
breathe in come forward plank
exhale lower nice and slow
inhale push the floor away
exhale thighs to the back wall
bend your knees look up right foot
forward
left
foot
inhale reach to the roof
breathing out arms wide stand tall
one more round breathing in
exhale diving forward letting go
hands to shins
touch down
left foot way back with the foot if you
can
feet hip distance feel your palms and
heels pushing down
take a deep breath in come forward into
your plank
exhale lower with lots of control
breathe in push the floor away
straighten the arms now breathing out
push back
bend your knees look up
left foot one big step forward just like
this
feet together come on in
take a deep breath in just breathe all
the way to the top
and exhale open
step your feet out wide we're going to
work on standing strength so feet nice
and open
left foot turns in right foot out
bend your knee
now just check that the knee is sitting
above your ankle for knee safety
body centered
shoulders relaxed and arms wide to the
side
we're gonna use the breath now already
inhale reach to the top
and the hands just lightly hold your
elbows like this
sink a little lower only if you want to
inhale lift up
the hand just gently touch the back of
the knee
reach into your sun warrior
can you feel that stretch down the right
side of your body
that's where we should channel your
breath
are we gonna stay here any longer
i promise you we won't
windmill over come on over
elbow to the thigh
top arm over the ear
listen top shoulder pushes back
nice and open through the chest
take the arm down we're gonna bring it
into a big circle reaching back
you can stay here or touch down if you
want a little challenge today
come on up we've got the other side so
just turning that right foot in and the
left foot out
make sure the hips to the front
and arms wide to the side
so we want to check for knee safety
knee over ankle
body center
arms reaching out through the fingers
i said a little movement inhale reach
use your breath to lift you maximum
height here hands just holding the
elbows
depth in the legs if you can
breathe in chest up to lengthen
tip back
only as far as you can go
top arm just lightly touch the back of
your knee
reach a little bit more and feel that
strength and sun warrior
can you breathe down the left side of
your body
hey come on over let's go
take support with the elbow to the thigh
top shoulder pushing back
so we're open to the chest
the arm comes down
it's like drawing a big circle around
for shoulder mobility
so choose to stay or touch down if it
feels good for you
come on up
just pivot on the heels we're gonna turn
to this side of the room check out my
back foot we're on the toes with the
heel up and reach through the hands
sink into your legs
and just gently tip forward so we want
lengthen the arms strengthen the leg
hands down
to the back
imagine there's a golf ball between your
shoulder blades and we're squeezing it
now take a deep breath and come on up
and over to the other side
front knee bends
breathe in to reach
gently tip forward
try to keep your back leg straight
that's going to give you lots of work in
the butt hands down
and wings out like a jet fighter
good job come on up breathe in we keep
moving and then turning to the front
look at my feet heels and toes out
and just gently hold the top of the
elbows
over to the right side
[Music]
good one more to the left
all right come on up release the hands
oh
we're gonna work on your balance now
that's gonna challenge your muscles your
core and you know what your mental
strength gonna start with three pose so
we've got options level one here with
the right leg halfway heel to knee or
all the way up
hands to your heart find your center
just check to make sure that knees out
to the side in line with the hip
softening through the shoulders
so if i were to ask you to make a
footprint on the floor how would you do
it
we breathe i'm going to challenge you
today by moving the arms
oh no
inhale we reach to the top
maximum height with the hands
good you ready for a bit more
right hand gently to the knee
side bend over
keep breathing
palms meet
it's okay if you wobble or you fall
lift up
think about softening through the
shoulders
melt your shoulder blades down your back
good
right foot take a step to the side bend
your knees cross through the hands we're
going into star pose
so you can keep your foot on the floor
or just experiment with it
by lifting that leg up
if you're falling over feel free to
touch down
we're gonna take it a little further
oh half moon pose coming up hand to the
floor so just cup the hands you're on
the fingertips
if you want a bit more work straighten
your standing leg good are you breathing
right now or are you holding your breath
[Music]
bend the knee we are coming up
for the next one you can have your feet
hit distance
or feet together because we're coming up
on your high heels so we lift up on the
balls of your feet
and heels up as high as you can
hold it there
slowly come on down
tree pose on the other side so you know
what's coming up
take the option that works for you
push the knee out to the side in line
with the hip
hands to your heart and find your center
find your breath
inhale open wide to the side
exhale reach
think of it like a big tree
firmly rooted into the ground
and growing right up to the sun
soften through the shoulder blades
left foot
hand to the knee
good keep pushing your foot into your
thigh or wherever you are
tip over
palms meet
oh i'm a little shaky here can you tell
lift the hands up
step over
big bright shining star show me
big bright shining star come on
lift that leg up
hold it open your hands like they're on
fire
ready where's the floor
why is the floor so far away oh my
goodness
come on up i've got good news for you
we're gonna sit down for this one
all right come on down we're gonna work
on the hips
so heels together and butterfly pose or
we call it badrasana now hands go behind
think about lifting the collar bones
good
we could stay here all day
but we're not
feet down like this
bottoms up everyone
right over left
cross it over take a seat back down
if this is too painful for you you can
move your foot away
there you go
you want to try
one hand
or both hands
lift the chest you know why i don't want
you to smell your foot
not a good idea
hands come on down
chest up everyone we don't want to hunch
over your leg we're taking it to this
side now so just roll over here
into your seated half lotus
you should not feel pain in the knee if
you are i need you to take this option
either down on your calf or here on the
floor yeah whichever option you are
need you to move your bum back so you're
on your sit bones
nice and tall we always want the good
dancers posture right
take a deep breath in come on over so i
guess if we're gonna touch hands
take a deep breath in again and as you
exhale
chest down
just melt
just let go
soften through the shoulders we don't
want any tension on the upper body we're
focusing on your hips right now
hands to the front
take a deep breath in here we go
so you might find your bum lifting off
the floor i want you to sit back as much
as you can
reach your hands
as far out as they can go
i promise you we're not staying here
hands on the shoulders we are coming up
and we have the other side so ready
hands behind
lift the bum off the floor
left over right cross it over
take a seat back down
remember your options foot away if it's
too much
and try this
hand
both hands chest up nice and tall
we want a nice long spine yeah
could sit like this the whole day
joanna is going to hate me for that hand
feeling
tight
over to this side now
good
options
either on your calf on the floor of it
feels good up here you can move your bum
back
you want to make sure you're on your sit
bones so that when you lean over it's
less stress on the lower back chest up
shoulders relaxed no tension
no stress
take a deep breath in exhale come on
over
[Music]
good stay here think about pressing your
right bum down so both sit bones are
grounded
breathe in again and as you exhale just
melt chest down to your thigh so you
want the shoulders nice and relaxed
tuck your chin look down on the floor
move your hands to the front like this
take another breath in stay here
and as you exhale reach your hands out
sit back as much as you can
soften through the shoulders
find your breath
wherever you feel any tightness any
tension
see if you can channel your breath there
hands on the shoulders to help you come
back up
coming back to where we started so we've
got the butterfly pose again so if
you're really tight in the hips you
might want to move your feet away it's a
little easier on the hips trust me on
that one
okay hands just hold above the ankles
inhale chest lifting up and
it's like falling asleep
nice
and after all that we are going into
your pilates so help your knees up
like this we're gonna roll onto your
back
table top pole so that means
knees over hips
push your back down you'll feel your
tailbone lift up that's good because
that means your core muscles are engaged
stay here we've got lots of work coming
up for your abs you're ready
foot step down
circle knee out to the side on the foot
tap
knee out and in push your back down
don't move your body we got one more to
go
oblique twist and reach check this out
elbow to the knees stay here reach up
other side twist
and reach two more to go
can your elbow touch your knee
keep lifting the chest
tuck your chin in to protect your neck
coming back to tabletop so legs together
just check that your knees are stacked
over the hips we're pushing the back of
your ribs down
tailbone lifts up
good no tension on the shoulders yeah
one tap one knee circle
keep pressing your back down
don't move your body
light toe tap yeah don't crush your toes
are you breathing
inhale to the nose
exhale from the mouth
breathe in the tap
breathe out to circle
one breath one movement always remember
that
last one tap
oblique twist and reach could we go
can we aim higher
can you touch your ankle oh my goodness
that's so far away
it helps if you have short legs like
mine
twist
and reach
take a deep breath in
exhale
come on aim high guys
can your elbow touch your knee
keep moving we are not stopping now
very good benjaminis we are coming up oh
into your plank so
check to make sure
proper alignment shoulder elbow wrist
step
you can be on your knees or toes
but push through the hands we don't want
to sink this way yeah
chest up
hold it here
stay
nice we've got two tabs coming up tap
and in
tap
in
tap
in
how many more how about 100 more i'm
kidding
two more
good everyone come down on the elbows
yep you can stay in your plank or lift
the knees up you want to do this
commando crawl we got one
two
three
four move back opposite arm and leg
stay and hold
oh my goodness knees to the floor and
sit back child's pose just reach
we're gonna lie back down
face up in your bridge pose so come on
down check that your feet are hip
distance and you should be able to just
reach your heels we're peeling off the
mat
one vertebrae at a time
feel the squeeze in the butt the work in
the back
and slowly roll back down again
got one more of that this is for spinal
mobility and we're strengthening all the
muscles in the back of your body your
lower back butt muscle hamstring
hands can stay or clasp behind but roll
your shoulders under your body
single leg glute bridge you're ready
knee in
toes to the roof
bend your knee
now gently place the foot down with lots
of control
other leg in
big toe to the roof
knee
and foot down two more to go
aim high push into your bottom foot go
higher with the bum
good job guys we've got one more
all the way up if you can
bend the knee
gently place the foot release the hands
we're gonna roll down again i want you
to imagine your spine is like a string
of pearls and we're lifting one pearl up
at a time
how's that feel
rolling back down laying one precious
pearl on the floor
very good
come on up
we
are on the hands just like this again so
again check shoulder elbow wrist stacked
tuck the toes
coming into your plank hold it here one
knee in
into your plank
knee
to plank
keep crunching in with the knee
look down on the floor don't look up
two more to go
one more
got plank pull backs two pulses into
plank
one
two shoot forward plank hold
one
two
shoot
i want you to imagine you're like a
rocket launch and hold sit back
and hold brace your core
take a deep breath in now
exhale plank
one
two
hold
two more one
two and hole last one
i've got a challenge for you stay here
with one foot off the floor
oh my goodness
switch change other foot up
don't rock your hips check that your
hips are level
back to your plank hold it here
and three
two
one
knees come down sit back child's pose my
favorite pose
i wish we could stay like this the whole
day
oh
are we still breathing yes
i am
barely breathing
okay
i promise you the next one is a bit more
relaxing
okay bend your knees like this 1990 it's
like a mermaid pose
so hands can go behind to help lift you
up
try to look as graceful as you can
hand over to your knee
now that bottom arm acts like your
second spine so push into it lift the
chest up
you're gonna turn away and look back
you know what your eye focus helps you
hear
what is the furthest thing that you can
see right now
notice that when you look further
it takes you further in your twists
experiment with that one
just breathe
find your breath
now turn around take a look at this
back leg just bring it around
you can shift that bottom leg away if
you need
check to make sure you're sitting down
on both butt cheeks
hands over here so again we always want
that length in the spine good posture
breathing in back arm reaching up
all the way to the roof
elbow on the outside of knee
and we're pushing your thigh to the
belly
that hand on the floor just like your
second spine it helps prop you up
and again we're breathing into those
areas that you feel tense
i've got a challenge for you try this
with me hand holding the outer edge of
the foot
and then reach that back arm
so again check that you're sitting down
on both butt cheeks
you want to go further
let's do this
how high can you push that leg how much
can you press the heel away
bend your knee always come out safely
from the pose yeah bend your knee first
and we're over here now
with both knees bent
hands go behind just to lift the chest
we're trying to look as graceful as we
can
that hand goes over your knee
bottom arm push to lift the chest
and we're turning to the back
so remember
use your eye gaze to help you go further
try to look back as far as you can
turn around face the front
just sliding that back leg you can move
that bottom leg just to set up correctly
and again make sure this
is pushing into the floor
hands on the floor to
lift you up
just relaxing through the shoulders
breathe
and the back arm comes up you ready
one deep breath as you reach
length
breath
elbow
outside the knee
keep pushing thigh into the belly
chest lifts up
how's that feel for your back
it's excellent if you have back pain
tightness in the back this is really
good for you
let's take this for the hand holding the
outer edge of the foot opening through
the chest
you can keep the knee bent if it's too
much or you can press your heel away
keep lifting the chest we want a nice
long spine
bend your knee
come on in just sit cross-legged
we're just gonna end the session nicely
so i need you to interlock the fingers
like this
take a deep breath in we lift through
the hands like as if you're holding the
ceiling with your hands now
look up if it feels good for you
but i need to soften the shoulders by
sliding your shoulder blades down your
back
breathe in can we go a little higher
with the hands
and as you exhale just imagine pushing
the walls away
bring your hands down
fingertips on the floor
however you want you can press your
palms flat down but we want to lift
through the collar bones so you're open
through the breathing space in your body
and i'd like you to inhale
deep into the center of your chest
all the way around to your belly
[Music]
coming over hands to the front
take a deep breath in again and as you
exhale just melt
tuck your chin in soften through the
shoulders
just connect with your breath
take a look here the hand
right hand goes to the corner of the
room and you stack your left hand over
or as much as you can reach so even if
you're here that's perfectly fine but i
need you to sit back on that left bump
now
channel your breath down the left side
of your body that's where we feel that
stretch
moving over to the other side
right hand just gently cross over
wherever it lands just let it be
[Music]
tuck your chin in look down to the floor
push your right bum down
and just breathing down the right side
of your body
hands to the front we're coming back
here
take another breath and see if you can
go just a little further now
or you can stay
[Music]
come up slowly it's much easier when you
slide your hands under your shoulders
just like this to lift the chest to come
back up
we're gonna finish with nice three deep
breath in so inhale to reach
now as you exhale just let your palms
come down like this
two more to go breathing in
feel that breath
soften through the fingers feel the air
under your
hands and
one more take a deep nourishing breath
in
and then let it go
hands to your heart
and find your center
we end our practice here today
thank you so much wendy
that felt so amazing you know i'm i'm so
used to doing quick workouts hit
workouts strength training and that just
totally brought me back down to center
myself and to really feel the stretch
and honestly i was struggling just to
look graceful throughout
thank you for joining me today joanna
thank you so much yeah and if you
enjoyed the workout let us know in the
comments section below if you want to
see more of wendy doing pilates or yoga
workouts then do let us know and
i really want to get you back again
thank you so much thank you so much